started? Okay, we have a few new people on the Zoom call today. We start off with questions
that you submitted. With our Wednesday Zoom calls, we do allow live questions to 99 percent of
the time people chant in those questions. So feel free to chat in a question any time it pops
in your head. I won't actually answer that question most of the time until we get to the end of the
ones that we're sent in. Okay, let's get started. On the homepage of your member's site,
remember I'm updating that usually multiple times a week. We have a direct link for the Zoom
calls now. You don't have to register. If you do register, then you'll get reminders for the Zoom
call. But you can just click the direct link just to make it easier to jump on the Zoom calls now.
Cheekswap testing. We already everybody knows about that. Just to make sure you please fill out
the Cheekswap form. You could do it online form now. Just so I know what to be seen for specifically,
you know, there's, you know, I want to be specific to what your desires are. So if you're like,
you know, I'm having hard palpitations too. Can you check for that? You know, put that on the the
forum. So the more detail you can be on the request form, the better, and the more specific I can
be in the testing. So try to do that. And you know, you can print it out and send it with your Cheekswap.
That's just fine. Or you can, you know, online, whichever is easier for you to do. Just if I could
get that. And then you can pay for the Zoom test right on the member site to just ask that you do that.
That would just save us some man of hours, women hours, people hours here, if you do that.
Oh, reminder that everybody is all of you can jump on any of the courses, user, same username,
and ID, user name, and password that you did to create the help for your member site.
And the blog is accessible only to our members. So make sure you just, you know,
click that little eyeglass thing, spyglass thing, and you can type in a question. There's 900 blog pages
and growing. So a lot of your questions might be answered on the blog. So you think of something
you're trying to search for. You could search for it using that little search tool. It might be on
the member site pages somewhere. It might be on the blog, somewhere. So try to search for it.
That'll save you some time. Okay, ready for you. The questions. I just had a CT scan and a couple of
questions. Media, item, chest, wall, Tyler area, right, breast, mass, seed, prior exam measured this.
Today's exam measured this. So it's changed or today's exam measured this prior exam. So it's shrug
almost in half, you know, so that's very good. And then they give an impression. So whatever you look at
CT MRI X-ray exam, they might go into details for the doctor. And then down at the bottom usually
there'll be an impression, which is a summary. So here's the summary. Number one, decreased
right, breast, massed, right, axillary, axillary, your armpit added up at the, that's an enlargement
and right in your chest wall nodule. This is consistent with response to therapy.
So they're just make, the radiologist is making a comment that it's decreasing because this person
is doing some sort of therapy. Right, lower, low, nodule, slightly decreased in size for prior exam.
Multiple new enlarging, sporadic densities. And that's what the question is found in the skeletal
area, you know, likely representative healing anesthetic disease. Once a sclerotic density.
So a sclerotic density is in, so when bone heals, so if you have a fracture, so if you fracture,
your arm, what's saying? And then you took an X-ray right afterwards, you'd see the break.
But then you took an X-ray three weeks later, you'd see a sclerotic density, sclerosis,
sclerotic is a term used for bone and increase in density and increase laydown of bone.
Now it can be from a fracture that's healing. Now eventually, usually there won't be a sclerotic
density, maybe six months post fracture healing because your body balanced that out. So you wouldn't
see an extra density there. But as it's healing, you're going to have an increase in bone density there.
That's called sclerosis. So if there is was metastatic disease, meaning a cancer that had
metastasized to a bone, remember I said, when cancer metastasizes to the bone, it's 99% of the time,
it's a lytic lesion. So lytic lesion is completely different than sclerotic lesion.
Lesion just means what we see there. So something going on. So lytic lesion is a bone
eating away. It's it's it's loss of bone density. The sclerotic lesion is an increase in density.
So when a cancer is healing, so let's say there was a lytic lesion metastasis to the bone and
that cancer is dying, now your body's going to heal that lesion with an increase in bone density.
So when you see sclerotic densities, sclerotic lesions, sclerotic sites on the bone with a person
that has has had history of metastasis, that's always a good thing. So sclerosis on the bone is a good
thing if it's healing density. Now you're going to get sclerosis in a joint. That's not a good thing.
That would be like in an arthritis situation. So if I am boldly arthritis, let's say,
from use arthritis or what's called a degenerative arthritis, also known as an osteoarthritis,
I will have a sclerosis of the joint. That's not good. So you got to increase laid out of
the bony material in the joint. The joints are supposed to be enlarged and movable. If you have
an increase in calcium laid out of the joint, it's less movable. If you have more of a bone on
bone type situation. So when you see it in a bone, post metastasis, that's a good thing.
When they measure a tumor on scans, can they tell if there is cancer under the tumor? Or is it just
a shell? No, they typically can't, unless the tumor is calcified, which typically doesn't calcify.
There's some long tumors that will actually calcify, but most of the time it abreast or something like
that it won't calcify. So it's hard to say. You could have a pseudo enlargement. We've spoken about
that dozens of times. When you look at CT scanner and MRI, it's cold standard, but it's far from
cold standard, truthfully, because you can get a pseudo enlargement. It looks like an enlargement,
but it's actually an immune attack to the cancer and you can't really tell what your measuring.
The tumor markers are also decreasing. So that's great.
I'm very excited about the results. Thank you for your team. Thank you for all you've done.
So you're very welcome. Give all the credit to God. He's healing you. He's using all sorts of
ways to do that. We're so thankful for that. This is why you look at multiple markers. So you don't
just look at an X-ray. You don't just look at a CT scan. You don't just look at a PET scanner and MRI
or blood tests. The more ways you can look at it, including looking at subjective findings.
You're going to have a better analysis of progress of disease. Next question. We got an email from
TrueRife about a deal sitting in your model F117. Correct. So this month, if you said it,
you have an F117. So they came out with the F122 about three years ago or so. So most everybody
on here, I think, has an F122. If you do have an F117, you can upgrade this to an F122 for $1,500
during February. So just call TrueRife. You can upgrade it. What's the advantage? Is
I'm upgrading. So I have a number of F117s at my office for use. My office, my kids, my
never. I have an F117, an F122 at home. I'm upgrading it to an F122 simply because I do think that
there may be a time where the F117 might not be supported. They might not support three pairs on it.
So I think if you do have an F117, that was a perfect time to upgrade it for $1,500. We just
send it in to TrueRife. They turn around and send you a brand new F122 for $1,500 plus $35
shipping. I think that's just a steal of a deal. It's a great deal. So I would suggest you do it.
I am gaining weight so bad. It doesn't stop. So when you have weight gain, usually cancer patients
don't have weight gain. This person is doing real well probably in revision. But what you do
want to look at with weight gain is a number of things. So again, I'm not a weight loss specialist.
But definitely look at get your thyroid readings back. We'll thyroid panel. We talked about what
the definition of that is. First, it's talking about everything that they're doing and they're
still gaining weight. So it's just how is this possible? It's very, very difficult.
One of the things with increased weight gain with everything you're doing, you want to look at
possible food sensitivities. And the reason why is that if you have food sensitivities, hidden food
sensitivities, and you're eating those foods, you're causing this inflammation even though you're
doing eating really good food, so the way you have to get that done is you have to do a Syrex
Array. It's called Array 10. That's what you would really want to do with a case like this.
I don't do you recommend taking blue gals orally or topically. What if you do not have cancer diagnosis?
What about the caplets? First of all, I'm not a real big band of blue gals,
brand. It's just I like the iodine that is more kelp based iodine. Most iodine does have potassium
iodide in it as well. Most iodine supplements, but some have some kelp based nutrients in it as well.
That being said, should you take it orally or topically? You will absorb some liquid iodine
topically. So you can do iodine topically. If you have breast cancer, you can put topical iodine
right over your over the tumor site close to the tumor site. There can be benefit to that,
but oral iodine is beneficial as well. We have our I think it's called clear
iodine selenium plus iodine product. That's the one I recommend to most people.
Biotics research has a liquid iodine. I think it's called iodine 4k liquid iodine 4k. I think what
is what it's called. That's a good product too, but the clear selenium plus iodine is my favorite one.
That's a capsule. What's the benefit of iodine? The benefit of iodine is you need iodine to make
tea tree and tea for in your thyroid. Iodine also can be beneficial with horrible driven cancers.
So breast cancer can be a factor and need for iodine. Also, iodine can be protective of your
thyroid in the case of your take the radiation or your exposed to radiation. That would be another
reason to take the iodine. So those would be the reasons to take the iodine. But we've got to
remember iodine is that's a mineral, but you can overtake. You could take too much of it. So I would
just use what's what is suggested on the bottom of this is a safe dosage. I would have biobact be
incorporated in my protocol. So biobact is an infrared heat source. That's really what a biobact is.
They may make all sorts of other claims. I'm not against biobats. I think they're nice
great heat sources, but I don't believe in a lot of the other claims that they make
selenium products. That's just my opinion, but I'm not against biobats. So they're good
infrared heat sources. We have other infrared heat packs
on our store. Biobat is typically a large one that you lay on. There's no harm in doing that.
There's no harm in using. You can use that in your protocol. You can use it on your bed. That's
totally acceptable. Can or should I drink raw milk? No. That was raw milk better for a person that
pasteurized milk. Well, sure it is. Pasteurized kills any of the positive good enzymes in it.
Of course, raw milk, you've got to make sure that you're getting it from a good clean source.
So you shouldn't try to inspect the farm. We used to help friends of ours melt their cows,
and we used to get raw milk from them. This was years ago, but they had a real clean buyer.
Captured me up to please use yourself. Captured it very clean, and there was, you know, so we trusted
the source of, you know, that milk. But we also, we had no other people that we saw their
barn. It was disgusting. It was just horrible. And there's no way I drink raw milk on those other
people's barn. So you do want to look at that. Secondly, why should you be drinking raw milk?
Should you be drinking raw milk with the cancer diagnosis? Typically no. Milk has other growth factors
in it that could, you know, increase the growth of cancer. So the answer is no.
Should you be drinking eating raw cheese? No, you shouldn't typically not be eating raw cheese
with the cancer diagnosis. Now, I know that on a lot of you, I have recommended no dairy. So
there's no dairy made absolutely positively not one speck of dairy. Okay, I've said this, you know,
a thousand times, maybe a hundred times, for sure. That's not even exaggerating. That your diet is
your diet. It's not a religion. It's not something that you have to, you know, steal all the joy
from your life to keep it. Certainly eating butter is a whole lot better than for you than a lot of the
plant-based spreads and stuff. So if you're not consuming a ton of butter every day, you can certainly
continue to use butter in appropriate fashion instead of the plant-based spreads out there.
There's just a lot of things that are good for you in the bad oils. Certainly using olive oils,
certainly using coconut oil. Those are good oils to use, but I really don't see any real benefit
for any cancer patient drinking milk of any kind, whether it's raw or pasteurizing.
Chai practice, who has been helping me with supplements, wants me to do a NutraClear 15
metabolic cleanse from biotics research. I would say no. We have this product in our store,
a lot of people buy it, but not our cancer patients. This is not something you need to do. You're
doing a cleanse with everything that you're doing. You are cleansing. I would suggest that you spend
a little time log on to the seven phases of detox course and understand detoxification.
Detoxification isn't doing a 15-day cleanse. Detoxification is a daily process that never ends and
you're supporting it with everything that I have you on. You don't need to do a cleanse like this. Now
I'm not against this. I'm going to get somebody doing these. It's not something you need to do.
Concerned about consuming so many capsules even though they're vegetable cellulose or some good
ingredients. Is it okay to open up the capsules and mix it with water, make a paste, wash it
out with water, or you can put it in your smoothie. The only one you can't is you've got to look at
sure model and make sure it's not a time-released product. If it's a time-released product that
no, you shouldn't open them up. But if it's not a time-released product, you could open up and put
them in your smoothie. Sure, absolutely. You don't need all those capsule products and ingredients
in your diet. Absolutely. Are there things that you shouldn't take at the same time? No.
I don't have anybody on things that really you shouldn't take at the same time. The only thing
that you got to be careful taking the same time is taking a homeopath. You should really take
homeopath at an empty stomach. If you take an SEAC, it's better to take that sip that for 15 to 30
minutes on an empty stomach. If you're taking protocell, then you're taking that away from all your other
supplements. That's about it as far as what I have everybody on. Rectocancer, second colonoscopy
showed seven polyps that were removed during the colonoscopy. I suspect the colon in the tuber
had increased in size. I am however feeling better with more energy. There were no tests to check
by on metastasis. I am scheduled for an annual visit. What test should I ask? The test to check
for metastasis, the best test would be a PET scan. I don't know why they didn't recommend that.
Many times understand they don't recommend a scan because the insurance doesn't pay for it or some
silly thing like that. That's what I would ask for as a PET scan. Okay, this person has staged for
prostate cancer. Please describe or paraphrase terms your comments on
blocking testosterone and IL-6. Okay, radiocologists that treat prostate cancer patients insist on using
the endogen deprivation therapy. That's what blocks testosterone. Androgens are male hormones.
They give it that way. Testosterone is an endrogen. The theory is that testosterone increases
the growth across the cancer. It's based on the endogen receptor on cancer cells. It's highly
admitted to the binding dihydro testosterone. You can block this receptor of the general positive
response. Many cancer patients have after beginning this. It looks like you just copied and pasted this
from their website or something. There's research that shows that specific endogen receptor AR-3 is
activated by testosterone, stimulating normal prostate growth. In prostate cancer, it is thought
that testosterone over effects this receptor in a sense. However, somehow the receptors become
hyper-reactive to testosterone-quasiting excess growth. This is called AR-3 over expression.
It is thought that searching genes are become overexpressed. Okay, so
it is. Okay, so this is using loop road or another endogen deprivation therapy can dramatically
reduce. This actually looks like it's from my blog or from my blog. Reduce PSA levels and even
greatly slow cancer, slow growth for a period of time, then the cancer tends to reappear with
vengeance. How can we address this? Okay, so that is a very true statement. Matter of fact, any
honest oncologist will say that we'll talk to a person with prostate cancer and push them towards
endogen deprivation therapy. We'll say that it typically only works for about one to three years,
and then the cancer can come back with revenge. So how can we address this? While it has been shown
this that elevated interleukin-6, IL-6 is a major mediator of this inflammatory response. So
interleukin-6, this gets back to your question. Interleukin-6 is what's called a cytokine. So there's
certain chemicals that are made that are signaling chemicals in the immune response.
And these are different interleukins. Interleukin number six is a hyperinflammatory cell mediator
chemical. So if we can reduce interleukin-6, it can really help in many cases. It serves a
purpose, but it can be overly, it can be an over-response and a laboratory response. So
decreasing interleukin-6 anyway that we can can be helpful. So what are some things that can
decrease interleukin-6? Well, I think in my blog, which I really should update it, because at the time
I wrote the book by blog, it was in all the literature, it was really the only thing that really
reduces interleukin-6 is EG-CG, which is the active ingredient of green T-extract. So green T-extract
has a ketican called EG-CG that has been shown in dozens and dozens of studies to decrease
interleukin-6 levels. Well, now there's been new studies that come out that resveratrol,
and even curcumin to some point, but resveratrol and EG-CG from green T-extract are the two main
components that can reduce interleukin-6. So this is true when I've talked to you about this that
interleukin-6 is one of those inflammatory cytokines, the brain inflammation,
in early dementia, Alzheimer's, Parkinson's disease, etc. So it's
a flavonoid that can be very beneficial for us. Also with prostate cancer patients, it's been
shown that end-or-graphic has been greatly beneficial to help with people that are doing
energy deprivation therapy to prolong the effects, the positive effects of energy deprivation therapy.
Now we will say there's new studies out on the energy deprivation therapy that are not positive,
they're not positive that it actually prolongs the life of the patient and it's almost
given that. If you do energy deprivation therapy, your PSA is going to drop dramatically. You could
have a PSA of over a thousand, start in a loop run, and your PSA can drop to zero. It's dramatic,
but there's some studies out that don't show that it actually decreases the progression of the disease,
just because it artificially drops your PSA doesn't mean it actually is solving the problem,
PSA is just a miracle. I've heard from a couple different sources though, the benefit of a 21-day
water fast for treating cancer. In one case, I heard a tumor shrink you about 50 percent within the
21 days. That was a colorectal tumor, which is similar to what I have. I have also heard lower back
pain from a prostate tumor going away completely within three days. You have comments on the value of
a full water fast treatment for cancer symptoms. Well, I think we just addressed this question
this last week too, that there's plenty of evidence that doing the fast over 24 hours increases in
IGF-1 levels, which is a growth hormone factor, which that's why most people don't recommend doing
more than a 24 hour fast per cancer patients, because it will increase IGF-1 levels. But I have had
patients that have done a 10-day fast, a 7-day fast, a 21-day fast, and even a 40-day fast, and it
really helped them. The only thing you have to really be careful of is the second half of this
question. I am a thinner person, 6 150 pounds. That's pretty tiny. If you're doing a 21-day fast,
you're definitely going to lose weight. I mean, definitely going to lose weight. And the one of the
worst things for a cancer patient is to fall into the trap of Cakesia, meaning that, oh my gosh, I'm
down to 135 pounds, and now I can't even put on weight. That could be a really bad thing for a
cancer patient. That could be a tumble that you can't get on it. So if you were thinking of trying
a longer fast, whether it be three days, five days, seven days, ten days, or even something like this,
I would say, don't try it unless you have some weight to lose. So, oh boy, I could lose 20
pounds, or I would still be, you know, not being too thin. Well, then that could be something that
you could pray about and try. Not against trying things that maybe go against some of the research
out there. Hey, the research isn't perfect either. If you feel like God's leading you to something,
try it, but you also got to be wise. And if you're at, you know, weight like this, I don't know
that that's a wise thing to do. I wouldn't, that wouldn't be my first go to. Yikes, I've just heard
about people using their old aged urine to get lots of stem cells into their bodies, both by drinking
animals. Have you ever heard this? Yes, I have. But understand, you don't want extra, you know,
stem cells, and you don't want stem cell stimulators in your body if you have cancer, because stem
cells are premature cells that can differentiate into something that you don't want it to differentiate
into if you have cancer, and you could differentiate into a cancer cell. So you want to try
drinking your old urine that's up to you, but I would do some more research on that.
Have you ever heard about AHCC? Yes, that's a component in different mushrooms that I write about
that in my mushroom book. So download the mushroom book, and you could read about that in there.
When I read the right value, it says download and install the latest frequency updates. So if you
just got a right from us, it's already been done. How often should you download and install the latest
frequency updates? I'd say about every three to six months, you have to put your take your computer
off of airplane mode. Remember, we tell you to leave your computer on airplane mode and do not
run Windows updates. Do not run any Windows updates. Do not run any computer updates. The only
updates you want to do is RIFE updates. If you do that, in the RIFE program itself. So there's videos
in the RIFE section and in the RIFE frequency course of how to do that. So make sure you don't run
updates for your computer. Just log down your computer and get a whole bunch of ad garbage that we
have deleted off your computer. So don't do that. Do you recommend that I turn my machine on at 9 p.m.
so that I can turn off after the program finishes before I go to work? No, I wouldn't say that.
Just you can let it time out. Let's say you get up to leave. You can just flip the
the program off. You don't have to do anything with the computer. I mean, slip the
your RIFE machine itself off. You're going to get up and leave. Just
reach over and click the off button on your RIFE machine.
Where can I purchase the maryotic acid to clean my, by any hardware store, what have maryotic
acid? What is the terminal matrix heater and tube and what I need it for any treatment in my
breast cancer? No. The terminal matrix heater is the heater for your, for the ion pro wave water.
You know, that's not anything you need. It says no kale or very little. This person is talking
about their genetic review information. And reason why you don't want a lot of kale with cancer
patients has to do with your, well, they have to do with your AWS genes. But it also has to do with
kale has the highest amount of nitric oxide is, you know, for any vegetable. I mean, by far
spiddages number two, the kale has probably three to four times the nitric oxide.
Nitric oxide is great if you don't have cancer. But if you have cancer, nitric oxide increases
what's called endothelial growth factor. Endothelial growth factor increases your ability to grow new
vessels, what's called that Jeff vascular endothelial growth factor increases the ability to grow new
vessels into a cancer which will then feed the cancer and allow the cancer to grow more readily.
So you don't want to be taking nitric oxide supplements. You don't want to be taking a lot of kale.
You can have some kale in your salad. But don't we make it kale smoothies or anything like that?
Collared greens is fine. You're fine. Take me there. Clear dip. I'm very sensitive to ashwagandha
in jinsing. Can I take the clear dim pro or the clear dim advantage? Yes. Or maybe just take the
easier aroma clear. That would probably be your best product. It's just a clear practice.
That'd be another thing. ADK or ADK veil look both look identical because they are the same product.
So we have we have a private labeled ADK veil which is decides for health product as ADK completely
could use the same name. All the same product has 5,000 I use a vitamin D.
But your vitamin D is person's say my vitamin D is already at 150. Well I really need you to get
the vitamin A out of there. So I'll email you a different product for vitamin A. It was because of
a gene that you have a gene defect you really need some more vitamin A. So just hold off on that and
I will get you I will email you a different product to take to get that vitamin A.
Last to it all the supplements previous and always feel ramped up. What would that be for the
TV go? No. Would that be for the corsetid? Yes. It's probably from the corsetid. It would not be from
the beda gene. Beda gene would actually probably help call you. Corsetid is going to help decrease
inflammation in your brain quite readily. TV go well too but it will be a slower process
and it could you can feel amped up after that. So that's not uncommon. I've decided to get the
horrible blocker treatment that my oncologist suggested in order to try and aggressively shrink
right here positive breast tumors. In my mind while the estrogen is blocked I want to double down
and they program to kill the cancer. My goal is to have no cancer left to cut out. I don't know if
this is realistic but I like to try at least and at the very least have a less involved surgery.
I think you just got to keep a very positive mindset if it gets a great goal to have.
I'm supposed to start two injections at a pill on Friday. I want point in my treatment should I
send a cheek swab to get the next phase going strong. I'd wait till you know after your take this for
after your other injection probably three days after this so maybe next week. So Friday this week
you're doing this maybe next Tuesday. I said another cheek swab. Are there supplements that I should
have on hand to combat the most common side effects of induced menopause? Well again you know like we
said the side effects of this induced menopause are from a decrease in your estrogen levels
and we could give you a whole bunch of different things that would that would negate that
but they'd be all estrogen based. They'd be things that oh you have you know that a person
going through natural menopause could take for typically soy,
um, isol flavonoids from soy. You can't take those. You really can't do those. So the body aches and
pain certainly anti-inflammatories could help that like curcumid and vasqualia and you know
those kind of things could help that. The vaginal dryness you're just going to have to use some creams.
You can't use any progesterone products. You can't use anything that's going to be an estrogen
stimulator. Fatigue I would just say adaptogens, hot flashes, maybe macaroon. Some of the adaptogens
would help with that and brain fog definitely the anti-inflammatories. The same thing you'd be
taking for the aches and body pains, the flavonoids, the curcumin, the resveratrol, the vasqualia,
the white willow bark, the quercetin, those are the things that would be good for that.
Decided to go with seven weeks of radiation five days a week and low dose chemosis planted once a
week. They told me H.P.V. related squamous cell responds well to this treatment plant.
By genetic test came back with a P-16 marker. I will also have a feed-in tube and they
are requesting Kate Farms formula. Kate Farms formula for feeding tubes way better than anything else
out there on the market, so that's good. A question is what kind of supplements should I make sure
to have a hand to comb out the short-term side effects of both ulcers, dry mouth, and skin irritation?
One thing that I would take is that product that I talked to about before. I think it's called
Clear Solidium Plus. I think that's what it's called. You'd call it in the office. That's our private
label of the third premier, or excuse me, the special health products, product of sletti on the
thionine. That would be the one that I would take. That will help protect your thyroid. That could
help protect some issues with the radiation. The dry mouth, I'd be swishing with coconut oil
and skin irritation. They do have a cream that they will give you. Some people have also used
just coconut oil on that. You could put a little bit of essential oil in that as well, like fragrance.
Anything that can keep my throat from swelling anytime you think of swelling in pain,
you go back to those flavonoids that we've talked about so often. EGCG, curcumin,
boscwellia, esvera, stiggy, nettle, white willow bark, those are the things.
A lot of those are in our product called Clear Inflamm, or the AI product has that in there.
Those things are there too, but Clear Inflamm is probably a little bit cleaner specifically for this.
We also conjured about long-term effects, difficulty swallowing the taste change.
They're going to be hard to get around because there's damage with radiation to your taste buds.
The difficulty swallowing would just be going back to those flavonoids and hear them hard.
One thing you might want to think of too, if you ever trouble swallowing,
kills as the liposomal curcumin can be really helpful. That can be helpful.
The product gland supplement helps with that. The product gland supplement will help
just protect the product gland and help with production of saliva. That's what that will
help with, which was going to help many of those things, especially the dry muds.
Considering taking the oxyplush colon cleanser, which is supposed to have an oxygen-based cleanse
on it, here's some ingredients. Okay, so I could go on half-hour story about this, but
I'll agree with you. There's a NASA scientist who invented the magnesium oxygen
combination to give oxygen in the intestinal tract. He was paid by a group of a supplement company to
produce this as a supplement. This company gave him a percentage of money down,
I'm simplifying the story as much as I can here. They were going to pay him the rest after they
got the complete formulation. We left out a piece of the formulation because this supplement company
kind of cheated him. All the magnesium oxygen products on the market actually don't work
like the research shows it will work. I don't need to be a stickler, but they are stealing the
research that he used from NASA and claiming that that is valid in their product, but actually
there's something that he left out of the product so it doesn't actually work.
Well, this scientist was actually then developed a relationship with the owner of the
parent company of US enzymes. The parent company of US enzymes, who makes a lot of enzymes,
for a lot of the supplement companies out there, developed a relationship with this guy,
the guy who holds the parent company of US enzymes. I know him, he's one of those overachievers,
he's climbed every of the highest mountains. There's a term for somebody who's climbed all the
peaks mountains. Is this overachiever, single guy at 40 something, and he's made himself a
become probably a billionaire, but he just is a super anal person who wants to do everything right.
It isn't really concerned about money. Well, he developed a relationship with this NASA scientist
to develop this oxygenation of magnesium that could help kill stuff in your gut. Well, in that
relationship, this guy, the guy who's the owner of the US enzyme, his first name is Troy,
said, I'll help I'll create the machine that can do this for you and we'll go have some and I
don't need the money. Well, US enzymes produce the product, actually went and visited that
the US enzymes parent company and Troy gave the end dust in and about six other doctors, a tour
while they're finishing this machine, we got to actually see the machine. Well, the product that
they have produced and they still don't even market it is so long story short, don't take that product,
take this one, it's called cleanse
enzyme, it's supposed like this, if it's next I am, that's how you're selling. Cleansime by US enzyme.
So we have it in our store, this is the product you should take, it's far superior product,
it's actually made by the NASA Harvard scientist who developed the technology and got all the patents and
and then all the other companies are not using the right formulation and really it's not an expensive
product and it's that is how you get oxygen to the oxygen-based tissue to the colon, oxygen-based
magnesium to the colon. So use that product by US enzyme, anybody can take it, it's no, it doesn't
hurt anybody, it's not necessarily necessary for everybody but anybody can take that.
Okay, to the questions here, I was unable to start my supplements from you until a week and a half
ago but was doing a lot of my old supplements from the RVCC protocol, three month cheek swab is due
what you know, should I still do it or wait until I've gotten a bit on your supplements, yeah,
I'd wait until you've been on this supplements for a little bit longer. Are you familiar with liquid
hope? Yes, what is your thoughts if I'm not eating enough? So yes, you could do it,
that's fine, I had to look at, you know, the last time I looked at the ingredients,
I was a couple years ago, so I like to go and look up to the ingredients of it. If I don't think
it is right, I'll email you, I'll have to look at that, but one of the peptides has got more proteins
in it and I, I'll have to look at the ingredients of it. I ordered clear digest and protein
enzymes from you and wondering if this will help my system as I am having terrible bloated gas,
let's skate bars. Yes, I would try the digest, the clear digest, that's what I recommended would
make it ask me about what would be the best thing for you. And remember, with your digestive enzymes,
you want to titrate them if you're having issues like bloating and stuff. The titrating means I'm
going to take one with a meal, but I didn't really help them still getting bloated, and next, then
tomorrow I'm going to take two with a meal, but you can go about three, four days, I'm trying to titrate
up slowly and titan titrate down, or you get to a point where you might have to take like six or
seven per meal until finally, wow, this is really helping. Then you start to titrate down.
You don't have to be on that kind of dose forever by any stretch of the imagination, but you might have
to titrate up to really get your body working, and then you titrate back down in a kill.
Well, okay. Is expelter expressed cutola oil an acceptable oil? No, no, cutola oil is an
acceptable oil in my book. Any, you could use expelter expressed sunflower oil or sap flower oil
or, but I would not use cutola oil. Are you familiar with stout bars? If so, do you think they're okay,
organic dates? Yes, I think they are okay. I've had them. They're very good.
I'm back from the immunotherapy institute to one of the Mexico Surgeon,
public polypsize lymph node on my right armpit. The known cancer is on the left side,
going to have a PET scan and probably a double mastectomy. No, they don't know what else to do.
That's okay. It's all right. Also, considering low-dose chemo in Mexico, post-apop, if they say
if I need it, Mexico does not think I need radiation. They will provide post-on treatment
suggestions after the tumor has been analyzed at the surgery. I don't have enough fat for
elaborate construction. What do you think about all of this? Suggestions for pre- and post-surgery.
I can send a cheek swab test. That would be the best thing, so I can review that.
I'm not against doing surgery. That might be the best thing to, you know,
you've got an active cancer that keeps popping up in different ways.
Debalking can be the best thing to do sometimes. So, don't feel bad that you
fail because your desire was not to have surgery. But sometimes it has different clients.
So, we just got to go with the flow sometimes and see the direction of God's ligaments.
Two months after the gut detox, which helped me a lot, I started Herxine and still continues,
although doing copycatamins in sauna, I need some to give detox for whatever causes this.
Is there a supplement to help besides charcoal?
So, you have to really define what Herxine is. So, you might not be Herxine having true Herxiber
reaction. You might actually be having some food sensitivity reaction to something you're eating.
So, just because you're having symptoms of a Herxine reaction, it could actually be an immune
stimulation with an autoimmune. So, getting some other testing might be valuable.
So, if you have a local practitioner that will do a Cyrex test, either a Cyrex 10,
which will test the food sensitivities, or a Cyrex 7, and 5, and 7x, which will test for
antibodies. So, understand, just because you have cancer, it doesn't mean you don't have
other things going on. You could have an autoimmune issue. And you're doing immune stimulation
to kill your cancer. Well, immune stimulation can kind of spark an autoimmune reaction,
which then you got to weigh out. You know, I'm trying to kill my cancer. Well, I get up to deal
with this autoimmune issue. I kind of put that on the back burner, but if you're in remission,
that it might be good. This is why we talked about pulsing your supplements. Go
way to week off your supplements and see if it decreases that reaction, because that could be an
autoimmune reaction. Your immune system is being stimulated, and you will kill that with you have
antibodies against first, which if you have self antibodies, it's going to affect your thyroid,
if you have Hashimoto's or something else. So, I do some further investigation. I'm not a big fan
of using symptoms to just say this is a Hercs reaction, because so often it could be something else.
Outside of the metastasis question, would blood tests be recommended? Absolutely. So, doing
blood tests, too. So, what kind of blood tests should be done on a regular basis? A CBC,
which will measure your blood cell count, make sure you don't have any type of ademia going on will
be really good. A complete metabolic panel, so complete metabolic panel would measure like your
liver function tests, make sure that everything's working well there. Those are your two most
common things to do as far as blood tests go. And then if you want to get into looking at
tumor markers, those are more specific tests. But your CBC and complete metabolic panel, that would be
the standard thing you'd get done is with your wedding, you got your annual checkup. They would do that
with a very minimal. If uses tumor markers would only be for someone who has a history of cancer.
Do Google, or not Google, sorry, do search on that little search bar for tumor markers,
and you'll see my blog post about tumor marker tests to get specific on what tumor markers might be
appropriate for you to run data on your cancer. And then there's other things that you might run.
So, other blood tests like if you might want to get a complete thyroid panel, you might want to get
a complete lipid panel. So, if you're concerned about, you know, your cholesterol balance and triglycerides
and things like that, those are the other things that you could do. I have been tasting a lot of
metal lately after I do dry brushing, castoropax, infrared soda, and rebooted. Do I take a break or
just keep doing those things? I just keep doing those things. Feel bad when I'm detoxing. Don't have a
lot of energy that have my eyes twitch. I make sure you're getting it up mid-erls. You know, if you're
getting eye twitching, you're doing solidas and such. Make sure you're getting it up mid-erls.
If you're using key laders like zeolite and everything, you could be key lading some of your
mid-erls out. So, make sure you're taking some mid-erls and getting some mid-erls. Here in the liquid
cult is much better than cake farms. It doesn't have enough sugars like cake farms. So, maybe true.
Totally started radiation on Monday and when I was first chemo on the end of Friday and
what point you said in a cheek swab? I think that I answered that. You want to give it about three
days, four days after you start that protocol. How about PEOs? PEOs were dryness. That is parrot oil. So,
parrot oils were dryness. I would, when I'm formal blockers, I would use coconut oil. Like I said,
you can use expel air-press, sap lower, and sunflower oil. But I use coconut oil and olive oil.
You're two best oils. With the heavy metal phase zero assist, metal ex synergy product, is it best
to use cell core binder, heavy metal ET to flush these out? Yes, you could, or you could use our
clear binder. Cell core binder is, their binders are good. Their, I like our clear binder. It's
a little less expensive. Cell products are a little pricey. And so, our clear binder, it's also
caused, it's called phase five assist, I think, is a really good all-around binder.
I have a licensed dietitian and she asked me if I could get a copy of the cheek swab results. So,
the cheek swab results are just what I give you. So, I don't have a printed result sheet for you.
It's just the changes that I give you. So, the testing is done with kinesiology and prayer and
so I don't have a printed result type thing. You're welcome. Do you happen to have favorite natural
sleep remedy? I have followed one by eating sleep, but it has a THP component that I just have never
heard of. My favorite natural sleep remedy to try is the insomnetol. Insomnetol is a product
well from designs for health. Those are just verbal formula. If there are some polyopathic formulas out
there, that can be beneficial too, but insomnetol is my favorite one, has now told in some different
herbs, just your calling brain calling herbs. CBD can be beneficial for that first leave too.
So, if you have a CBD at home taking that, you know what I mean for that can be beneficial as well.
Okay, a lot of good questions tonight. Just remember to keep sending your questions in on the forms
and on the member site. You check in the member site and keep looking at the member site and using the
blog. We could either go right to the blog there and search the blog or you could just search here
and I'll search the blog and the site. So make sure you take advantage of that. Also take advantage of
all the other courses that you can jump on and learn a bunch of stuff. Seven phases of detox,
probably your most loved one. All right, though I'll be praying for all of you. You guys are in my
prayers daily basis. I love you all and I'll get this recorded up and we'll talk to you guys next week. Bye bye.